[Musique]
je te veux du bien de près ou de loin
avec ou sans
moi je te veux du
bien
heureux malheureux tu pars où tu viens
aimer
malaimer je te veux du
bien tu ne m'appartiens pas tu
n'appartiens qu'à
toi je suis comme un rocher où tu peux
t'appuyer
oui je te veux du bien de près ou de
loin avec ou sans
moi je te veux du
bien heureux malheureux tu pars où tu
viens aimer
malaimer je te veux du bien je donne et
je reçois mais pas ce que tu
crois je n'attends rien de toi je t'aime
trop pour ça un jour tu partiras je ne
t'en voudrai
pas surtout si tu t'en vas sans te faire
mal à
toi
[Musique]
je te veux du bien de près ou de loin
avec ou sans
moi je te veux du bien
heureux malheureux tu pars où tu viens
eter mal
aimé je te veux du
bien si je comprends bien Maxime tu veux
du bien à tout le monde je veux oui je
veux du bien à tout le monde mais si
veux tout le monde c'est c'est très
vaste j'aime je crois tout le monde mais
je n'aime pas tout dans tout le monde de
même que je n'aime pas tout en moi il y
a des choses que je que je déteste chez
les êtres mais je crois que je n'ai
jamais rencontré une seule personne que
je déteste complètement totalement je
crois que dans chaque personne tu
trouves quelque chose d'extraordinaire
même dans un
chien dans certains chiens on trouve
l'affection même quand les chiens sont
serviles esclave on trouve l'affection à
limite des êtres qu'on qu'on ha parce
qu'ils ont fait beaucoup de mal à
l'humanité on peut certainement trouver
chez eux quelque chose de de beau de
touchant donc oui j'aime je veux du bien
je crois à tout le
[Musique]
monde
j'ai lancé la
bouteille
tu o tu es j'ai lancé la bouteille à la
mer s je
suisvragé
j'ai d'être là face à rien face à
moi je pour l'horizon d'où tu viens les
soirs de délirees où j'invente un
[Musique]
navire j'ai lancé la bouteille à la mê
pour que tu saches là où tu es j'ai
lancé la SIL à la mer pour que tu saches
je suis
nafragé j'ai lancé la bouteille à la mer
pour que tu saches là où tu
j'ai lancé la bouteille à la m pour que
tu saches que je suis
enfragé dis-moi Maxime tu es breton mais
bien sûr Maronne du Conquet non des
blancs Sablon comment peuton être sur
une
[Rires]
plage
j'ai beau m'en
défendre je ne ris pas
souvent bien que je sois
tendre vin me rend méchant c'est la
faute du
vent il est des histoires que l'on dit
aux enfants j'ai dans la mémoire trop de
Man naufrageant par la faute du vent qui
n vient
N qui a vu Moline a vu sa p
mais qui voit où est s'en bois son
sang quand on est breton m'a dit ma
mère on a du chagrin pour 2000
ans trop de joie
m'inquièes notre ciel est
changeant les plus belles fêtes me
laissent un peu tremblant c'est la faute
du vent c'est la faute du je viens de la
Grèce mon
pesant accuser les rêves le cri des ha
et et devant vous
respire qui a vu mine a vu sa
peine mais qui voit où est sen voie son
sang quand on est breton m'a dit ma
mère on a du chagrin pour dem000
[Musique]
an
dis c'est quoi la
mort la
mort c'est comme une chenille qui
devient un papillon la chenille elle
sait pas qu'elle va devenir un papillon
mais le papillon il sait pas qu'il a été
une
chenille je pense que c'est ça la mort
ou alors tu vois lorsque tu chauffes
l'eau ça devient du gaz de la vapeur
d'eau la vapeur d'eau elle c'est pas
qu'elle a été de l'eau je pense que
c'est
ça quand il y a de la boue sur l'océan
il faut se méfier des corgant gare au
passant trop bon vivant qui vont tout
seul et que la nuit
surprend soudain autour de toi ils
étendront leurs bras Gael dans le joyeux
délire de leurs éclats de rire gaë il te
faudra chanter il te faudra danser
devenir le panttin de ces sacrés
luuttins quand viendra le matin toi qui
parlais si bien
Gaël tu auras 200 ans et le regard trop
grand
gaelll tu sauras des secrets que tu
devras cacher toi l'enfant de chez nous
dans la maison des
fous
je ne sais pas quand j'ai perdu la foi
ça doit faire quelques années
déjà et pourtant dans une église moi je
parle tout
bas et malgré les croyants qui
oublient leur amour quand la mess est
fini moi qui crois ce que je vois j'ai
peur de faire du
pas
savoir ce que disent les vit des
églises et pourquoi je reste là étonné
sans dire un
mot pourquoi va
savoir ce que disent les vitrux des
églises et pourquoi je reste là et te
niss dire un
[Musique]
mot je compare un peu l'enfant à une
plante qui a besoin de tuteur si tu
laisses l'enfant aller n'importe où
n'importe comment tu lui donne des tu
lui fais beaucoup de mal il faut l'aider
à à progresser il faut le soutenir
jusqu'au jour o bien sûr il n'aura plus
besoin de
toi je voulais insister sur le fait que
un instituteur un professeur qui est
trop gentil avec ses élèves qui leur
laisse tout faire leur fait du
maluren est all l'instituteur nous a
quitté il était trop trop gentil je
crois qu'il n'a jamais puni pour lui
l'école c'était la fête c'était le plus
bel océan apprendre aux enfant
d'aujourd'hui comment
grandir plus haut que
lui pas
assez dur pas assez méchant les oiseaux
se perdent quand le ciel est trop grand
pas assez dur pas assez méchant il faut
vivre avec son
[Musique]
temps tout éclier cache un poète un
musicien que l'on rejette avec la peur
avec l'ennui avec des gestes bien appris
comment le dire à des enfants qui vous
insulent à bout portant comment leur
parler de la vie quand chacun d'eux
vous
crucifie pas assez dur pas assez méchant
les oiseaux se perdent quand le ciel est
trop à la p dur pas assez méchant ni
pourM son
temp pas assez dur pas assz méchant les
oiseaux se per temp le sel est trop
grand pas assez dur pas assez méchant il
faut vivre avec
[Musique]
T j'étais professeur pendant 5 ans celui
qui est professeur comme celui qui
chante a une très grande
responsabilité c'est difficile parce
qu'on a toujours tendance à vouloir
imposer ses
idées je crois qu'il faut être égoïste
il faut s'aimer beaucoup soi-même et
quand tu t'aimes beaucoup toi-même tu
peux aimer les autres tu pouras moublier
en toute
liberté mais quelle que soit ta vie je
serai ton
ami je te donne du bien de près ou de
loin
moi je te veux du
bien de malheureux tu pas où tu viens
aim
mal je te veux du
bien